they said is a rectangle and the length
of the rectangle is four times the width
it's four times as long as it is wide
okay so they give you those that
relationship they told you that
perimeter is that and then what they ask
for is the dimensions and they ask for
in the dimension okay
now on the face of it this question
looks nothing like the questions that
we've just been doing okay but
underneath it if you sort of dig a
little bit you'll find this exact
question let me show you I draw the
rectangle and we are told that the
length is four times the width so just
like we had over here let's put a label
that's the programmability to help us
now instinctively I could say length and
width but here's a principle for you in
mathematics if you can do see with
simpler writing like introducing less
letters and printers like I think that's
easier to work with right so since I
know that the length is four times the
width instead of course a whole new
letter L for length being that it's four
times or with I'm just going to call it
for number two would be no and that make
sense okay now if you recognize that
when you think about this this is
actually quite simple to soul based on
this information as provided because you
can write an equation that will solve
this for a nothing I can say the ribbon
are can be stated in terms of these
lengths here it's a rectangle so you've
got a four W key on and as I move here
yes if I so good so then what I can say
W plus W plus 4 W or W right that's a
state for the premiere and expression
for conversions
but that's already a known gumball I
knew that's equal to 250 centimeters
right so how many W I have a minor bug
test
hey guys so my point is if it doesn't
look like a problem to the equation in
it
the equations there if I dig a little
bit we can solve this question right
what's equate the solution to this
equation W equals 25 have I answered the
question I've always done it don't have
an iron I've got one of the dimensions
the width what's the other dimension its
4w right away is awesome that Rogerian -
and you're done okay now I could really
close this question so that you end up
with an equation so little boy it's
prison suppose I said to use another
primitive being that suppose I told you
that the area was equal to say this
everything else is the same
just suppose this is the question now
how can I use this setup in order to
arrive at the same or not attend
inductance but because of the cause of
this what would I write instead of this
it's an area is our blank touch with
isn't always times when society ever
uses so Madison area is w times or no II
do you agree yeah but just like before
this is a no value right this is a
hundred square centimeters so I can pay
for W square is 100 square centimeters
so now what I do is I can divide both
sides by 4 I'm trying to solve that
equation it's a quadratic raised to I'll
divide both sides by 4 which gives me
this okay so what W down
but whatever ice can be oh yeah ah now
what to pay attention you'll know in
this case we get to something like this
which looks just like the question ice
under what letter was just like the
question I gave you before and I said
watch out there's what what solution is
plus or minus 9 in this case here there
is not possible - how tall is it this is
a length you have to pay attention to
what your question is it's always a
temperature you can get negative
temperatures that's totally fine right
but it's the legs so I'm going to say
because it's only supply you're going to
get one value Oh I haven't quite
finished the question hello what's the
final package does that give you an area
often 2 square centimeters yeah say you
don't so you don't get presented with
the equation you have to construct the
equation by thinking carefully about the
information you've been given